thanks Sara now I'm here in the forest
because everything I'm about to do can
be done completely offline I'm going to
take a closer look at how it works and
how you can use it to view the history
of a file specifically I'll take a look
at game KS which contains the code from
the asteroids game you saw earlier since
I had been using git to keep track of
changes while writing this code I can
navigate to the directory where the code
is saved and type git log what I get is
every commit that's ever been made
starting with the most recent notice how
each commit has an ID an author a date
and a message associated with it
for now I want you to focus on the
commit message and the ID the message
explains what has changed since the last
commit and the idea is sort of like a
serial number it uniquely identifies
each commit and lets you refer to it
I'll scroll a bit by pressing the down
arrow so you can see the commits with
the changes we discussed earlier this
commit is where I switch to the control
keys to use space for movement instead
of up arrow this one is where I fixed
the typo and this one is where I
reverted the controls back to the way
they were before since I didn't like the
new controls scrolling back up to see
the more recent commits you can see some
commits by Doug doing things like making
an iPad version of the game and there's
also a commit by me adding some color
into the game to make it look more
interesting I can chuck what changes
that commits introduced by using the git
diff command git diff is similar to the
FC or diff program you used earlier but
instead of just comparing two files it
can compare different versions of a file
within git
right now I'm going to use git diff to
see the difference between these two
commits so first I'll copy the first
commit ID that I want and then I'll copy
the second and paste them both into my
command here when I hit enter I see the
changes made between the two commits if
you're using a Mac or Linux this output
looks very similar to the diff output
earlier all you need to notice in these
lines is that we're comparing two
versions of the file game Jas and here's
the actual diff you'll notice that git
supports the nice feature of colorized
diff so the black lines didn't change
the red lines with the minus sign were
removed meaning they only existed in the
first version and the green lines with
the plus sign were added meaning they
only existed in the second version these
two
to look familiar since they're the same
changes you looked at before here's the
typo you found